[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 30 novembre voici le
programme il s'appelle Buddy il a été
conçu pour devenir le compagnon des
personnes isolées fabriquées par
l'entreprise française de Blue Frog
robotique il permet également de faire
du soutien scolaire en continu notamment
pour les enfants touchés par des
maladies graves Buddy est arrivé dans
certaines écoles 50 chinoises nous en
parlerons avec nos invités dans cette
émission nous partirons aussi à la
découverte de Houdan une ville
dépaysante à la frontière d'Eure-et-Loir
rencontre avec ses habitants et son
histoire déambulation dans ses ruelles
médiévales et ses vastes chants mais
également à dégustation de ses
spécialités culinaires le premier
épisode d'une série sur nos communes
yvelinoise et le te dit c'est le jour de
notre page cinéma nous parlerons des
films à ne pas manquer dans les
prochains jours violente night Enzo le
croco ou encore à Nicolas au programme
également le coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du 7e art et avec moi en
plateau Régine rage bonsoir bonsoir
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78 ce
matin vous étiez à Paris au salon
éducate pour la présentation de ce
nouveau robot qui est d'ailleurs juste à
côté de vous Buddy oui effectivement
donc j'ai fait la rencontre du robot
Buddy qui justement accompagne les
enfants qui sont atteints de qui sont
atteints pardon ces maladies graves oui
voilà de maladies graves de pathologies
grave et qui est présent notamment dans
les classes à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et avec nous également pour en parler
Anne capiot bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère communautaire en charge du
projet numérique éducatif pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines également avec
nous Jean-Charles c'est Mama bonsoir
alors vous vous êtes conseiller péd
psychologique au numérique à l'académie
de Versailles alors est-ce que vous
pouvez un petit peu nous présenter ce
robot Buddy qu'est-ce qui va apporter
aux enfants alors ce robot est en
expérimentation dans des dispositifs
Ulysse ce sont des dispositifs qui
accueillent les élèves à besoins
éducatifs particuliers et on espère
pouvoir en faire une interface un robot
compagnon pour pouvoir accompagner le
travail des élèves le travail des
enseignants et donc on en parlera plus
en détail dans quelques instants mais
avant je vous propose de faire un point
sur la météo de demain
demain matin dans les Yvelines nous
devrions avoir un temps bien hivernal le
ciel devrait rester nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 5 à 4 degrés en
moyenne mais avec un ressenti de 2
degrés dans l'après-midi le ciel devrait
rester couvert compter 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et aux dents
et 5 degrés à Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons les florences le point
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines
le principal suspect dans la mort de
Djibril tué dimanche à Coignières a été
mis en examen pour meurtre sur mineur de
moins de 15 ans mardi 29 novembre
âgé de 16 ans il s'était rendu dimanche
après-midi au commissariat d'Argenteuil
dans le Val-d'Oise précisant être
l'auteur des coups de marteau l'effet ce
sont déroulés à l'issue d'un gala de MMA
au gymnase du moulin à vent de
Coignières l'immobilier en baisse dans
plusieurs départements français les
Yvelines sont en tête avec une
diminution de -4,4% des prix de
l'immobilier selon la startup ever
invest à l'origine de ce classement les
acheteurs ont repris la main les
vendeurs ne peuvent plus refuser de
dossiers novembre c'était le Mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire durant
tout le mois Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a
organisé différentes actions book des
acteurs webinaires une rencontre des
acteurs cette tenue aujourd'hui mercredi
30 novembre au ski cube et de neuf pour
le relais Val de Seine le réseau du
Mouvement Emmaüs a ouvert à plaisir ça
neuvième boutique l'entreprise
d'insertion collabore avec des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi pour s'occuper de
ces boutiques de le lendemain trois
espaces sont proposés au sein du centre
commercial au shopping grand plaisir et
c'est l'image mignonne du jour le zoo
safari de Thoiry a un nouveau
pensionnaire ce petit fourmilier a été
découvert accroché à sa maman cutsi le
14 novembre dernier le zoo a annoncé la
bonne nouvelle le mardi 29 novembre à
l'occasion de la Journée mondiale des
fourmiliers si vous souhaitez passer un
moment privilégié avec l'indé
pensionnaires du zoo tout Harry
conservation vous propose de les
parrainer les fonds récoltés sont
reversés à des associations et également
dans l'actualité cette lettre écrite par
la présidente de la région
Île-de-France aux usagers des transports
franciliens Valérie Pécresse leur
demande d'interpeller l'État face à la
hausse du prix du Pass Navigo pour
rappel ce dernier devrait s'élever à 90
euros par mois elle souhaite ainsi
mettre le gouvernement devant ses
responsabilités car avec le covid 19
l'inflation et le financement du Grand
Paris Express
Île-de-France se mobilitait face à une
situation financière très tendue et ce
sans soutien de l'État et si vous aussi
vous voyez une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le communiquer en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
le premier et le 2 décembre les médecins
libéraux feront grève les revendications
peuvent varier selon les organisations
mais toutes illustre un ras-le-bol face
à un manque de considération du métier
il demande notamment une revalorisation
des tarifs de consultation Julien Leroy
a interrogé Jean-Marie connaissa le
responsable départemental de la
Confédération des syndicats médicaux
français
[Musique]
ce sont tous les médecins l'initiatives
avaient été lancées par
un nouveau groupement qui est pas encore
assez syndicat qui s'appelle venir
médecine et à partir de là l'ensemble
des syndicats c'est-à-dire la totalité
des syndicats médicaux et Dieu sait si
il y en a pas de temps il a bien 6 ou 7
tous se sont jointes à cette initiative
du premier et du 2
[Musique]
essentiellement la décharge
administrative la décharge
administrative c'est à dire qu'on nous
donne les moyens d'embaucher du
personnel qui soit rémunérés bien sûr
selon son travail et qui nous décharge
du tiers au moins de notre activité ce
qui nous permettrait pendant ce temps de
voir beaucoup plus de personnes et
améliorerait le service de soins ceci
passe effectivement par augmentation de
la lumière rémunération ou bien par la
prise en charge de ces assistants
médicaux directement par
l'assurance maladie ou fusion autre
forme
toute personne qui dans la journée en
temps normal a besoin d'un médecin même
pour une pathologie qui n'est pas
urgente urgente mais qui veut voir un
médecin dans la journée appelle le 15 et
le 15 dispose de créneaux disponibles
dans chacun des territoires pour y
adresser des messages en principe la
régulation du 15 devrait être à petit
peu
chargé et renforcer au niveau de
personnes qui répondent
[Musique]
l'intelligence
logiciel au service de l'inclusion en
milieu scolaire telle est l'ambition de
Skippy Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
l'inclusion un programme porté par 50
ans en Yvelines et l'académie de
Versailles c'est dans ce cadre que Buddy
un robot émotionnel le conçu par la
start-up Blue Frog robotique a été
présenté ce matin au salon éducatech à
Paris et avec nous pour en parler Anne
capillo et Jean-Charles c'est Mama
bonsoir bonsoir alors Anne capiot
pourquoi
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a répondu à
cet appel à projet alors dans la
continuité des projets phares de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
des projets phares chers au président
Jean-Michel fourgousse qui est la porte
des outils numériques dans les
apprentissages scolaires il nous a paru
important depuis un certain temps de
pouvoir mettre ces outils numériques à
la disposition des enfants
qui se trouve dans une situation de
handicap donc nous avons répondu à cet
appel à projet lancé par la BPI pour un
projet qui va jusqu'à 2030 et nous avons
répondu à cet appel à projet avec la
société Blue Frog robotique et donc qui
a donc la société remportée cet appel à
projet pour pouvoir avec Buddy ici
présent sur le plateau mais Buddy dans
nos classes et ainsi permettre aux
enfants dans cette situation de handicap
de pouvoir acquérir de l'autonomie de la
confiance en soi et alors justement en
quoi peut-il l'aider ce robot alors on a
essayé de déterminer des fonctionnalités
qui regrouperaient des outils qui
peuvent parfois exister dans plusieurs
sous plusieurs formes et essayer de les
rassembler dans un dans un même un même
au jeu objet et d'essayer de pouvoir
avoir un objet qui va pouvoir
communiquer avec les élèves leur donner
des indications des repères ou alors
pouvoir leur permettre de faire des
exercices ou avoir des communications on
espère qu'il va aussi se leur servir de
de un petit peu d'objets traditionnel
dans lequel ils vont pouvoir être
rassurés avoir des moments un petit peu
isolés pour pouvoir se détendre quand il
y a des moments de tension
dû à la classe ou du à des tensions
personnelles pourquoi c'est important
pour 50 ans en Yvelines de s'engager
dans l'inclusion alors l'inclusion a
toujours été un sujet pour nous dans nos
écoles et comme on suit tous les projets
des outils numériques l'intelligence
artificielle est encore pour l'instant
utiliser de façon très épididique voilà
donc 51 en Yvelines qui est une terre
d'innovation
ça nous a semblé important de faire
cette expérimentation d'un robot pour
pouvoir aider tous ces enfants en
situation de handicap et on voit
l'apport de l'outil numérique dans les
apprentissages scolaires pour des
enfants dans nos classes et et les
enfants en situation de handicap était
un petit peu délaissées et on s'est
rendu honte par pas mal
d'expérimentations que que
l'intelligence artificielle pouvait
amener des choses donc on veut vérifier
sur place et on veut vérifier comment
cela se passe à l'intérieur des classes
alors je le disais il y a quelques
instants ce robot a été présenté ce
matin au Salon éducatech de Paris où
vous y étiez Régine rallès je vous
propose de regarder le reportage
le robot Buddy est désormais un élève 50
chinois il a fait sa rentrée scolaire
dans l'agglomération en septembre
dernier le but assister les enfants
atteints de troubles cognitifs dans leur
parcours scolaire
l'expérimentation en classe durera 18
mois
nos amis d'éducation nationale on
choisit cinq classes des classes de
collège des classes traditionnelles ou
des classes pour accueil d'enfance en
situation de handicap ce qu'on appelle
des Ulis donc 5 classes on s'est lancé
depuis un salon de l'année
donc sur la sur la R&D concernant bien
sûr ses enfants qui ont besoin
bien sûr d'être plus aidé certainement
que les autres conçu par l'entreprise
Blue Frog robotique en 2014 Buddy est
voué à devenir le compagnon des
personnes les plus vulnérables dotées
d'une intelligence artificielle il peut
interagir avec les personnes
âgées isolées ou aider au développement
des enfants hospitalisés ou en situation
de
handicaps donc des psychologues des
membres d'associations
des personnes autistes etc pour essayer
de cibler au mieux comment répondre à
aux besoins exprimés face à ce qu'il y
avait déjà été fait sur le marché avant
aujourd'hui 2000 robots ont été commandé
par le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il devrait être accessible au
grand public l'an prochain
alors on sait que Buddy a été déployé
dans 5 classes est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire dans quelle ville est-ce qu'il est
présent aujourd'hui alors actuellement
Buddy et présent sur la ville
d'Élancourt sur la ville de Plaisir de
Montigny et de Trappes donc dans des
écoles élémentaires dans des classes
ULIS qui sont des classes à
enfants a besoin particulier et dans un
collège d'accord et qu'est-ce qui fait
concrètement dans la classe a quoi il
sert exactement quels sont quel est son
rôle ou ses activités alors je vais
répondre en fait pour l'instant il est
on est dans une phase d'expérimentation
donc on a essayé de prévoir un certain
nombre d'interactions qu'il pourrait
avoir avec les élèves et on l'a pensé en
complément de toutes les de tous les
outils que possèdent l'enseignant pour
pouvoir aider les élèves donc on va
essayer de lui faire faire des
interactions avec l'élève avec des jeux
de cartes où il va pouvoir travailler
autour des émotions autour de sujets que
les enseignants eux-mêmes vont apprendre
à body pour qu'ils puissent s'en servir
pour les pour questionner les élèves on
va lui demander aussi de faire des
travails un travail de de récitation
mais même on a essayé de penser aussi
quelque chose autour de l'emploi du
temps de l'élève quand l'élève est un
petit peu perdu il ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer après si on va essayer de
faire reconnaître l'élève par body pour
qu'il puisse dire dans 10 minutes tu
sais que tu as la prise en charge avec
l'orthophoniste ou voilà on va essayer
que ça soit vraiment un outil compagnon
au même titre et on va essayer aussi de
développer une partie d'intelligence
artificielle pour qu'il puisse parler à
Buddy ok alors je sais pas encore sous
quelle forme il va l'appeler mais Skippy
ou Buddy ok
à quelle heure est la récréation toutes
ces petits repères qui permettent aux
élèves d'être rassurés et d'avoir un
cadre précis qui vont leur permettre
d'être de plus en plus autonome dans la
vie de la classe
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
l'avenir pour l'éducation
ça sert pour beaucoup de choses par
exemple on a de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les tablettes quand on
fait le dictées aux élevés donc on va
pouvoir permettre vous allez a besoin
particuliers par exemple dans le OK dans
le cadre de la dyslexie les élèves qui
ont du difficulté par rapport à l'écrit
on va pouvoir peut-être répondre et
dicter des choses à la tablette ce qui
va leur permettre de d'avoir une entrée
dans le monde de l'écrit Buddy pourra
peut-être faire ça on pourra lui dicter
des choses il pourra peut-être écrire
pour savoir ou questionner l'élève voilà
on va on va essayer de de tabler sur
cette mais c'est vraiment de
l'expérimentation pour l'instant on a on
a des belles idées et Blue Frog va nous
aider à les réaliser dans un
aller-retour avec eux très très régulier
et justement cette expérimentation elle
dure jusqu'à quand exactement on en a
pour 18 mois donc on est dans vraiment
la toute première phase c'est la
rencontre entre les enseignantes qui
s'approprient alors le lit a déjà été
montré en classe il a une attente
phénoménale des élèves parce que c'est
c'est mystérieux c'est ça fait un petit
peu rêver donc pour l'instant le les
premières fonctions ont été dévoilées
aux élèves alors il ne répond pas encore
mais on va expliquer qu'on va apprendre
à mieux d'identifier va devenir un élève
supplémentaire pour les élèves à besoin
de particulier c'est les élèves besoin
de particulier qui vont apprendre à
Buddy et c'est un rôle qui peut être
assez intéressant pour les élèves aussi
les enseignants exactement les
enseignants vont pouvoir s'en servir
comme outil pour pouvoir mettre en
autonomie des élèves ou faire une
interface quand les élèves vous savez
dans les dispositifs ne sont pas des
classes ce sont des dispositifs où on
accueille on accompagne les élèves à
besoins particuliers pour qu'ils
puissent avoir un accès à la classe
ordinaire donc il y a des allers-retours
dans ces classes entre la classe
ordinaire et la classe du dispositif et
donc ça va permettre de jouer ce rôle
d'accompagnement aussi est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres projets avec body à
venir alors bon alors donc comme le
disait Jean-Charles on est dans une
expérimentation de 18 mois parallèlement
à ça nous expérimentons à Élancourt dans
une classe um qui est une classe
réservée en maternelle pour des petits
autistes et là nous avons passé un
partenariat grâce aux Lions Club
d'Élancourt qui nous a financé un autre
robot qui s'appelle pas Buddy mais il
s'appelle le cas et les cas est aussi en
expérimentation dans cette classe pour
les petits de maternelles donc là les
fonctions ne sont pas les mêmes et on
n'attend pas la même chose de Buddy
comme ce qu'on attend de l'État mais
c'est aussi une expérimentation de
l'intelligence artificielle au service
des enfants et bien merci Anne capillo
et Jean-Charles c'est maman d'être venu
en parler Merci à VOUS hier matin aux
alentours de 9h un motard de 62 ans à
trouver l'amour écrasé par un poids
lourd à Port-Marly le drame s'est
déroulé le long de la départementale 113
les circonstances restent encore à
confirmer mais le moteur qui circulait à
leur modéré aurait tenté une manœuvre
conduisant à l'accident pour le maire de
Port-Marly Cédric Pemba marine ça
relance le débat autour du trafic é les
deux camions sa réaction au micro de
Julien Leroy pour Marly subit depuis
l'arrivée des deux nationales qui ont
coupé la ville en quatre au milieu des
années 60 donc c'est que le dernier
subit un trafic incessant et notamment
beaucoup beaucoup de poids lourds qui
viennent pas là pour la livraison du
dernier kilomètre mais qui sont là en
transit et selon des chiffres d'attente
de 2017 Port-Marly et traversé par 5500
camions chaque jour une préoccupation
pour les habitants le carrefour où il y
a eu ce grave accident hier et très
dangereux je ne passe jamais le long de
la nuit j'étais toujours peur il passe
très près sur deux voies dans chaque
sens c'est
inquiétant quoi si vous voulez
maintenant j'ai un bébé donc c'est vrai
que ça fait un petit peu peur d'avoir
des enfants qui qui traversent et tout
ça mais
après changement de vous dire on peut
pas faire autrement quoi c'est une
nationale faut bien que les camions ils
passent quelque part quoi le
contournement se contournement qui avait
été imaginé pareil au siècle dernier
mais qui avait été abandonné
certainement pour des raisons
financières il faut qu'on se dise
aujourd'hui que les raisons financières
ne tiennent pas face à
nos préoccupations légitimes de santé de
sécurité aussi des habitants depuis le
mois de septembre 2022 un espace de
coworking est ouvert dans la commune de
La Queue-les-Yvelines une maison en
plein cœur du centre ville a été aménagé
pour accueillir des entrepreneurs des
TPE ou encore des salariés le reportage
de Nicolas dandry ces espaces qui sont
des espaces des espaces à vivre plutôt
que des espaces de travail c'est la
caractéristique de cette structure de
coworking travailler comme si vous étiez
à domicile installé dans une maison du
centre-ville de La Queue-les-Yvelines le
salon les chambres ou les autres pièces
de la Bâtie sont été aménagés en espace
de travail un réaménagement jusqu'à de
l'ancienne piscine
une piscine couverte que nous avons
nous-mêmes recouvert d'un parquet et qui
va être une salle de réunion pour
l'instant vous avez les chaises on aura
bien sûr les écrans qui pourront qui
pourront servir pour les réunions et on
va bientôt y installer une table qui
arrivera assez seulement sous peu
cofondateur de cet espace de coworking
Olivier Renault et ses équipes sont
installés ici depuis 2007 d'abord une
agence de communication ils se sont
réorientés en 2019 vers le coworking
cette histoire de coworking c'est un
petit peu la continuité de ce qu'on a
fait avec l'agence puisque c'était une
agence qui a été primée au 4 place Tower
que parmi les les trois meilleurs
entreprises où il fait bon vivre en
France l'esprit on a voulu le faire
perdurer en offrant aux personnes qui
qui travaillent chez eux aujourd'hui
à l'espace où ils sont pas vraiment dans
des bureaux ils sont dans une maison on
est dans une maison de ville on est en
plein cœur de La Queue-les-Yvelines au
total 28 postes de travail sont
disponibles à des tarifs allant de 250 à
850 euros des espaces nomades fixes ou
des bureaux privés parmi les
utilisateurs installés il y a
l'entreprise Solier énergie une société
crée début 2022 spécialisé dans
l'installation de panneaux solaires nous
on a choisi de travailler au cowork à la
maison parce que ça nous permet d'avoir
une flexibilité de pou quand on
accueille des nouveaux collaborateurs
d'une part
de pouvoir grandir sans avoir la
contrainte de voir changer de changer de
lieu aussi pour la convivialité qui
apporte un espace de coworking d'avoir
d'autres entreprises avec qui travailler
d'entreprise entrepreneur ou société
entière peuvent s'installer dans cet
espace pour se sentir dans un
environnement comme à la maison
et nous avons été rejoints un plateau
par Guy Galanti bonsoir vous êtes avec
plaisir vous êtes le président de
l'Étoile sportive à Guyancourt alors je
suppose que vous avez suivi le match des
bleus des Bleus à chaud votre réaction
bon c'est un match difficile des joueurs
de qualité quand même en Tunisie il joue
presque tous enfin tous participés au
championnat de Ligue 1 et il participe
donc oui un match difficile parce que
beaucoup de jeunes sur le terrain de
notre côté
bon et puis c'est un début pour beaucoup
c'est difficile en Coupe du Monde
université était contre la Tunisie qui
elle avait un enjeu majeur c'est se
qualifié donc c'est exactement ce qui se
passe pour un match de coupe voilà nous
on était déjà qualifiés ou pas et bon le
différentiel est important au niveau
l'engagement de la psychologie l'abord
du match la Tunisie était prête nous un
peu moins mais bon après on a quand même
équilibré avec la rentrée de nos joueurs
cadres et donc bon le résultat 1-0 avec
quelque chose qui est un peu anecdotique
à la fin parce que normalement la règle
veut qu'une fois que le match est sifflé
la fin du match est sifflé on peut plus
revenir en arrière et là c'est pas le
cas la fin du match a été sifflé et
pourtant ils sont revenus sur la
décision et bon c'est bizarre mais
peut-être qu'il y a eu quelque chose de
changé avec la barre peut-être mais
normalement ce but aurait dû être
accepté parce que même la position
chacun des vitres avant de finir même la
position de hors-jeu me paraît très
aléatoire
et c'était notamment l'entrée de Matteo
Guendouzi il est venu Noah est-ce que
vous en avez pensé
de cœur Marseillais donc forcément gagne
12h samedi quelque chose bon je pense
qu'il a été comme tous et partenaire
jeune de l'équipe un peu pris par
l'enjeu par l'environnement mais bon
c'est un bon début quand même parce que
ces jeunes sont de qualité parce que
dans l'équipe de France des champs fait
quand même le pari d'avoir beaucoup de
jeunes les joueurs cadres qui étaient
des joueurs hors norme ne sont pas là
notre ballon d'or Pogba
il y a eu beaucoup de blessures
donc c'est beaucoup mais c'est bien
outre outre l'équipe de France est-ce
que vous avez un favori dans cette Coupe
du monde alors les favoris ouais il y en
a pas mal parce que on voit que je crois
que la France est la seule ou les grands
joueurs le grand joueur sont absents en
nombre mais le Brésil l'Espagne pour pas
ne citer que deux l'Angleterre aussi
qu'il faut pas oublier
il peut y avoir une surprise encore
parce que je vois la nature des matchs
je pense que ça peut générer des
surprises
même pour la France la France bon il
faudra qu'on soit au maximum de nos
possibilités mais je crois qu'on a quand
même une équipe très costaud alors vous
voyez qui en finale j'aimerais bien voir
la France
et peut-être remake France-Brésil
m'intéresserait beaucoup alors est-ce
que au sein de l'ES Guyancourt est-ce
qu'il y a un engouement autour de cette
Coupe du monde
bien sûr la preuve c'est que cet
après-midi on avait un entraînement pour
des petits six sucettes on l'a décalé à
14h pour pouvoir leur permettre de
regarder le match à 16h oui bien sûr
qu'un engouement vous avez prévu des
soirées pour des soirées on laisse le
club house à disposition de nos équipes
qui veulent regarder un match ensemble
passer la soirée à regarder le match il
y a combien de licenciés environ cette
année on a un record historique pour le
club parce qu'on dépasse les 750 ce qui
est jamais arrivé dans lequel on est
plutôt toujours aux alentours des 700 et
là on passe à un beau score difficile à
gérer mais beau score est-ce que en
général une coupe du monde réussie par
les Bleus ça engendre ça génère une
montée ça se passe pour les féminines
parce qu'on a des féminines dans le club
malheureusement ils ont pas été au bout
elles auraient été au bout je pense que
ça aurait fait vraiment le déclic pour
les féminines
au niveau parce que nous si on a quand
même à peu près 15% de féminine en plus
donc on était 60 en les 75 on vise les
100 féminines dans le club donc oui si
si ça a généré quand même un engouement
on voit de plus en plus de filles venir
au foot heureusement jusqu'à quand
exactement c'est quoi votre vous visez
les 100
j'espère qu'on y sera j'espère
beaucoup de lobbying auprès des écoles
notamment pour que des filles viennent
jouer avec nous vous espérez du coup qui
est plus de licencier grâce à cette
coupe du monde je pense je pense qu'on
en aura plus en plus ça s'arrête pas
parce que l'État fait quand même pas mal
de choses pour les licencier avec des
aides particulières notamment par le
département pour le plus et l'État pour
le passeport donc ça permet à des
enfants d'avoir des dotations en
subvention qui sont intéressantes qui
leur permet d'avoir une petite enfin une
licence chez nous
est-ce que vous êtes déjà allé à Houdan
vous dormez
je vous propose de partir à la
découverte de cette ville qui est située
à l'ouest de départements avec Céline
Charles nous sommes allés en apprendre
un peu plus sur son histoire son
patrimoine et ses spécialités culinaires
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à la
découverte de Houdan une ville
historique médiévale située à l'ouest du
département à la frontière
d'Eure-et-Loir ou dans vous offre une
jolie balade entre villes nature et
histoire de France on retrouve des
traces depuis l'époque néolithique mais
elle fut vraiment peuplée à partir du
12e siècle avec son donjon ses auberges
ces commerces atypiques ont vous guide à
travers ces rues et on part tout de
suite à la rencontre de Loïc pioche
c'est le dirigeant de la boucherie des
arts c'est le seul à vendre encore le
fameux
[Musique]
bonjour alors vous êtes le gérant de
cette boucherie et vous êtes le seul à
commercialiser encore le fameux Pathé de
Houdan et qu'est-ce qu'il a de spécial
ce passé
qui à base de viande de volaille
d'accord de la poule de Houdan 100%
voilà il n'y a pas de gelée de porc à
base de pistache Musson de champignons
avec vin blanc et un petit peu de cognac
et c'est 100% voilà et vous avez
beaucoup de clients qui vous en
demandent du coup pas mal depuis qu'on a
fait la confrérie il y a 4 ans le
concours on a une deuxième prix et on a
eu beaucoup de monde par rapport à ça et
tous les semaines on a des gens qui
viennent de loin pour acheter des
boutons
prenons le temps de se balader dans les
rues du centre-ville nous sommes tout de
suite plongés à l'époque médiéval les
auberges rue de Paris témoignent du
passé ville étape durant le Moyen Âge
[Musique]
et l'église Saint-Jacques et
Saint-Christophe surplombe la place du
centre-ville elle est classée monument
historique
[Musique]
à 5 minutes à pied le chemin de la croix
au pèlerins vous offre une jolie
promenade en pleine nature au bout un
magnifique panorama sur la ville
[Musique]
activités historique incontournables le
donjon de Houdan enceinte fortifiée
durant le Moyen Âge son vécu est
intimement liés à l'histoire de France
c'est parti on part à sa découverte
[Musique]
des prés bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
animatrice du patrimoine et vous vous
occupez notamment de ce donjon quel est
son histoire alors le donjon a été
construit à la fin du 12e siècle c'est
ce sont les dernières fouilles
archéologiques qui nous le disent qu'il
a été construit par la famille des
montforts d'accord on pense que il
n'était pas habité parce qu'il y a pas
de cheminée ici
on pense que c'était pour montrer une
puissance féodale forte sur la région
c'était peut-être aussi une tour
d'observation parce que on est il est
très très bien elle est très très bien
placé cette tour mais on pense aussi que
c'était pas forcément un des fins
militaire soit il y a pas d'éléments de
défense active qui nous indiquerait que
c'était un fort donc on pense plutôt
voilà que c'était une identité féodale
forte pour surveiller l'ennemi oui alors
de là-haut effectivement on a une très
bonne vue à 360 degrés donc sans doute
c'était une tour de gai mais il n'y a
pas de mâchicoulis mais il n'y a pas de
chemin de ronde il n'y a pas de
meurtrière donc c'est ce qui nous fait
penser que c'était pas vraiment un
bâtiment militaire mais plutôt un
bâtiment
d'apparat le donjon de Houdan proposé
également des concerts des expositions
ou encore des escape game pour faire
vivre ce lieu d'histoire
[Musique]
et vous pourrez retrouver à le reportage
en entier sur notre site internet la
commune de houdencigne le premier
épisode d'une nouvelle série sur nos
communes Yvelines le prochain sera le
mois prochain un portrait à présent
fanny est une comédienne en situation de
handicap à l'intégrer la troupe de
théâtre Eurydice de plaisir en 2019
Julien Leroy l'a suivi lors des
répétitions du spectacle heureusement
que vous êtes là regardez je crois qu'il
est plus par là ouais c'est ça
et le tien il est plus derrière ou plus
de vent dernière mise en place avant la
répétition générale pour Fanny cette
comédienne plaisiroise de 28 ans a
intégrer le théâtre Eurydice en janvier
2019 cet établissement du service d'aide
par le travail basé à plaisir en gage
des comédiens en situation de handicap
depuis 1986 un travail rémunéré attend
plein pour cette troupe de 9 comédiens
on a beaucoup de chance du coup parce
que tous les artistes ne peuvent pas se
vanter d'avoir un spectacle permanent
comme ça la plupart sont intermittents
et doivent chercher encore et encore
donc je pense qu'on a beaucoup de bol
fanny a commencé le théâtre à l'âge de 6
ans lors d'une représentation d'une
pièce de William Shakespeare en classe
de CP sa mère était fascinée par ses
capacités de mémorisation elle a obtenu
une licence d'études théâtrale à la
Sorbonne Nouvelle allez allez cultiver
allez
à un niveau intellectuel Ornans
très agréable de travail avec elle je
fais ça pour pouvoir m'amuser tous les
jours et honnêtement je ris tous les
jours donc je pense que je vais avoir
une bonne santé grâce à ça la troupe
repecte actuellement le spectacle
heureusement que vous êtes là mise en
scène par Cécile tournesol et écrit par
Roland Dubillard acrobate du verbe et
jongleur de mots se retrouvent sous un
chapiteau de fin du monde échange entre
ces deux clowns très bavards
elle est cassée on peut pas jouer avec
ça pas de chance pour une fois que je
gagne Fanny elle est très
impressionnante elle a des capacités
incroyables de de mémoire ce qui est
surtout aussi
formidable c'est qu'elle a une passion
pour le théâtre et donc voilà on sent
qu'elle est heureuse sur scène je
ressens tout mon corps je ressens tout
ce qu'il y a autour de moi je ressens le
public et et il y a quelque chose où
quand je suis sur scène je me sens
vivante la troupe joue actuellement
trois spectacles la pièce heureusement
que vous êtes là sera représenté les 16
et 17 décembre au Théâtre Eurydice de
plaisir
et comme chaque mercredi on passe à
notre page cinéma on commence avec le
coup de cœur d'un professionnel cette
semaine c'est Vincent Mirabel le
professeur de cinéma versaillé qui nous
parle du film Le Dernier vice roi des
Indes regarder le dernier vitroi des
Indes voilà un film que j'ai découvert
cet été à une période généralement il
n'y a rien à la télévision c'était sur
une grande chaîne publique et j'ai
tellement aimé ce film qui parle de la
partition de l'Inde juste après que
l'Empire britannique est quitté le pays
j'ai tellement aimé ce film que je suis
retourné au cinéma pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que c'est un film
absolument superbe moi qui ai vu
énormément de beaux paysages ou de beaux
costumes ou de beaux décors j'ai été
bluffé par la perfection des costumes et
des décors par ailleurs il y a une
figuration exceptionnelle des milliers
d'Indiens qui croisent la route
notamment de l'Orne bounbatten qui est
là pour assurer la session en douceur et
la transition douceur entre l'Empire
britannique l'Inde et le Pakistan ce
film est interprété par HUG Bonneville
également guilian Anderson qui a le rôle
de l'épouse de Lord moumbaten et qui
joue avec une grande finesse c'est un
film très délicat il y a en fait à la
fois de la politique extrêmement
intéressante puisque c'est une page de
mars 1947 que peu de gens connaissent et
par ailleurs il y a également une très
belle romance entre deux je dirais
domestique employés de l'ambassade
d'Angleterre et ces deux indiens dont
l'un et l'ancienne acteur de Slumdog
Millionaire vont avoir une liaison pas
systématique que ça ça n'est pas une
romance bollywoodienne c'est une vraie
histoire d'amour qui se fait avec
beaucoup d'épreuves donc on vibre tout
du long du film et voilà pourquoi j'ai
eu tout le temps envie de revoir ce le
dernier vice roi des Indes de gürinder
Shada fine de 2017 accessible aux
Européens bien Canadiens c'est un
spectacle magnifique bon spectacle et on
continue à de parler cinéma quels sont
les sorties aujourd'hui c'est la petite
sélection de Céline Charle un film de
circonstances période de fêtes oblige
les films de Noël arrivent sur nos
grands écrans mais Vaiana de Tommy
whirkola est un peu différent des films
classiques il nous fait le portrait d'un
père Noël un peu spécial sous les traits
de David Harbor Jim Hoper dans stranger
things le Père Noël a le blues et se
laisse aller il a décidé ce sera son
dernier Noël faute de magie depuis
plusieurs années mais lors de sa tournée
le 24 au soir il va se retrouver
embarquer dans une prise d'otage qui
risque de tout changer
dis-moi qui c'est parce que c'est pas un
père Noël de centre commercial
[Musique]
cette nuit
un film pour les plus petits mais aussi
les plus grands il s'agit d'Enzo le
croco de will speak et Josh Gordon une
comédie musicale mêlant prise de vue
réelle et animation c'est l'histoire
d'Enzo un crocodile fan de bain et de
caviar qui chante divinement bien c'est
d'ailleurs le chanteur Shawn Mendes qui
lui prête sa voix pour les scènes de
chant le reptile se retrouve abandonné
dans le grenier d'une maison jusqu'à ce
que de nouveaux locataires arrivent Enzo
va rapidement se lier d'amitié avec Josh
le fils de la famille qui va chercher le
protéger par tous les moyens
un film d'actualité maintenant il s'agit
Dany colère de Blandine Lenoir qui
traite de la question de l'IVG
l'histoire se déroule en 1974 un an
avant la loi veille Annie une ouvrière
maman de deux enfants va
accidentellement tomber enceinte mais ne
souhaite pas poursuivre sa grossesse
elle va donc devoir recourir à
l'avortement encore illégal à cette
époque et va se faire aider par les
bénévoles du Mouvement pour la liberté
de l'avortement et de la contraception
est-ce que tu as déjà avorté une fois
c'était avec quoi des aiguilles à
tricoter regardez c'est ça
pas possible jusque là c'est les hommes
qui ont le pouvoir de décider de nous
mettre en scintillante alors si c'est
nous les femmes qui pouvons choisir
et c'est la révolution
on termine avec le nouveau film de
Quentin Dupieux le réalisateur revient
avec fumée fait tousser une comédie
française à l'humour absurde comme lui
seul c'est le faire on suit une équipe
de cinq justiciers les tabacs parodie
des super-héros des années 80 pendant
qu'ils sont envoyés renforcés leur
cohésion le temps d'un séminaire à la
campagne le casting sera sûrement vous
convaincre on retrouve notamment Gilles
Lellouche Jérôme Niel Benoît Poelvoorde
Vincent Lacoste ou Adèle exarchopolos
est-ce que vous avez une préférence
Régine ouais totalement à Nicolas moi je
pense que ça m'intéresserait bien je
suis ravie qu'on en parle au cinéma et
puis c'est d'autant plus d'actualité
avec ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
aussi donc ouais ça sent très bien
intéressant quoi que aussi violente
night avec le Père Noël violence ça a
l'air drôle également ça c'est original
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant jetons un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
demain matin dans les Yvelines on aura
un temps bien hivernal le ciel devrait
rester au nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 5 à 4 degrés en moyenne mais
avec un ressenti de 2 degrés dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait rester
couvert compté 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
5 degrés à Rambouillet et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]